[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be discussing
a topic that i saw requested in the
comment section below it's a topic that
i've covered before but not very well
and today i want to do it justice we're
going to be discussing spells but not
just any aspect of spells we're going to
be discussing the visual component to a
spell now there are all sorts of spells
and all kinds of different incantations
but one thing is for certain the color
of a spell always attracts a lot of
attention voldemort zavada kadavra just
wouldn't be the same without that
sinister looking jet of green light
emanating from his wand and nor would
harry's bright red expelliarmus but what
i want to discuss today is what do these
different spell colours actually mean
well they simply arbitrary or are we
able to derive some sort of relationship
between the color of the spell and the
type of spell itself what is the
underlying meaning behind these spell
colors i think that the most obvious and
sort of go-to answer to this relatively
unaddressed question is something like
green spells are inherently dark in
nature red spells are inherently
powerful in nature and white spells are
inherently pure good and passive in
nature to name a few and i agree with
those sentiments for the most part
however i believe there is much more to
it than that and i want to peel back the
layers and uncover what it is that makes
these spells these colours let's start
by looking at a couple of common spell
colours green throughout history has
always been regarded as having some sort
of supernatural connection it is also
commonly associated with dark magic and
is coincidentally the same color as the
house of slitherin which gets a bit of a
bad rap for its affiliation with dark
witches and wizards slytherin's house
colours which are green and silver are
said to be connected to the element that
they most closely represent which is
water the killing curse itself is green
which is pretty much as dark and
sinister as you can get so i understand
this common connection between green and
evil furthermore spells cast with the
intent of death or suffering almost
always seem to be green
green can be extremely varied depending
on what shade of green you are talking
about but across a broad sample of
different greens it can still be shown
as implying toxicity illness jealousy
and potentially envy some examples of
what i would consider to be typically
green spells include avada kedavra the
killing curse imperio which places the
victim completely under the caster's
control
which conjures an enormous eerie image
of the dark mark
red on the other hand is generally
regarded as being representative of
energy passion and fire red along with
gold represents gryffindor house this is
consistent with the house's element
which is fire red spells are often
powerful and bear the potential to be
destructive in nature like green spells
but aren't necessarily evil or sinister
they are more likely to be used
defensively than offensively that is not
to say that they couldn't be used
offensively if the cast are wanted but
these spells are less commonly used to
kill or cause suffering to an enemy
harry's signature spell expelliarmus
proves to be extremely useful for him
but while fairly powerful it just
doesn't have the same feeling of
darkness that we see in a number of
strictly offensive green spells
somehow it feels as if it is cast with
the best intent red has an unspoken but
seemingly implicit element of warmth
comfort and security some examples of
what i would consider to be typically
red spells include expelliarmus which
forces whatever an opponent is holding
to fly out of their hand stupefy which
stuns the target rendering them
unconscious incendio which conjures of
jet of flames and fiend fire which is a
flame of abnormal size and heat however
fiend fire is the obvious exception here
as it is actually quite a dark spell
a classic example of a white spell is
the patronus which is bright white and
emphasizes hope purity and positivity it
is somewhat antithetical to spells which
are representative of darkness
this explains what is so effective at
warding off dementors as it represents
the very things that dementors aren't it
drives away darkness and dark things and
is powerful but in most circumstances
isn't destructive it isn't often used
offensively and it only exists to ward
off dark and sinister things i think
that red and green are sort of the main
powerhouse spell colours in the harry
potter universe and that all other spell
colours sort of circumvent these primary
colors green and red almost have a sort
of ian and yang relationship where they
are both powerful but represent very
different things i think that the other
colors share common attributes such as
being representative of elements but
despite there being powerful spells
which use these colors i think they are
less closely tied to a sort of
underlying meaning some blue spells
include reducto which is a curse that
blasts solid objects to pieces aguamenti
which conjures a death of clean
drinkable water and immobilis which
immobilizes and stops the actions of the
target as you can see these spells are
not necessarily as closely related as
say a grouping of red spells or a
grouping of green spells the same can be
said for other spell colours as there is
a less identifiable relationship between
different spells that utilize the same
colour this all sounds great right okay
now let's look at exceptions to these
general rules that i've sort of tried to
establish and this is where it begins to
break down a little bit exhibit a sektum
sempra sektim sempra is an extremely
vicious offensive spell that causes cuts
and lacerations on the target it was
created by severus snape with the
intention of using it against his
enemies by describing it it sounds like
it would fit into the same category as
avada kadavra as the only objective of
casting it is to cause pain and
suffering however sektum emperor is
actually white exhibit b crucio crucio
is one of the most sinister curses and
is used to cause intense and
excruciating pain upon a victim once
again this sort of sounds like it fits
into the wheelhouse of green spells and
it sounds as if it would come from the
same category as avada kedavra wrong it
is actually red this is where i'm forced
to get a bit more abstract in my
thinking i think this is where standards
for what spell colors represent might be
skewed it is my belief that the colour
of the spell can be heavily influenced
by the spell caster and that the colour
is not necessarily purely determined by
the spell itself this blurs lines a bit
and essentially what i'm suggesting is
that the relationship between spell and
spell color is more fluid than we might
have originally thought i think that
something we need to consider is that
the color may be influenced by how it is
being used and by whom
in almost every instance that we've seen
of vada kedavra being used it is a green
jet of light i think that it is
undeniably a green spell in almost every
circumstance and the spell itself is
green because of its inherently dark
nature however when snape kills
dumbledore in the half-blood prince he
actually uses avada kadavra the unusual
thing about this scene is that the jet
of light that snape produces is
definitely more on the blue side and not
the shade of green that we're used to
this could obviously just come down to
the filmmaker's preference but it
definitely looks kind of blue my theory
is the richer the color the more closely
resembles the values that it is meant to
represent in its purest form i.e the
purer the green the more evil the purer
the red the more powerful if a typically
green spell like avada kadavra is cast
with that intention that matches what
the spell itself represents then it will
be produced in a different color snape
clearly had hesitation when killing
dumbledore
and his true emotional state was
represented in the color of the spell
because snape didn't want to kill
dumbledore his reluctance showed in the
color of the spell that he produced i
want to discuss this aspect of the video
further but i'll save it for the next
one obviously there are other spells
besides red green and white i've just
mainly mentioned these because they seem
to be most prevalent one interesting
instance of a purple spell comes from
antonin dolorhov who seems to be able to
produce an offensive curse in the shade
of purple but the death eater hermione
had just struck dumb made a sudden
slashing movement with his wand a streak
of what looked like purple flame passed
right across hermione's chest she gave a
tiny oh as though of surprise and
crumpled onto the floor where she lay
motionless i think that it makes sense
that dolorhov's curse is purple because
like some shades of green purple implies
certain things like witchcraft
deviousness and sometimes even toxicity
i'll end the video here because i think
there are so many angles that you can
look at this from when you've seemingly
identified a relationship between spell
color and spell there always seems to be
an exception to the rule and that's what
makes this topic fairly convoluted and
difficult to discuss i'd love to hear
what you guys have to say on this topic
what do you think spell colors represent
are they bound by meaning or entirely
arbitrary that's it for this video until
next time it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]